so now we have decision time we're going
to need to decide whether to reject the
null hypothesis so as we've said a small
p-value
suggests that such a large value of the
test statistic is unlikely to occur
under the null hypothesis
okay so a small p-value gives us
evidence against h naught but is it
enough evidence well usually we need to
have a binary decision we need to either
reject the null hypothesis
or else fail to reject the null
hypothesis i should mention we never
accept the null hypothesis because we're
testing the null hypothesis we either
reject it or we don't
um but the the right vocabulary isn't to
rej to accept the null it's just to fail
to reject the null
so okay our p value is small that gives
us some evidence against h naught should
we reject the null or should we not
reject it
um well if it's really small we want to
reject the null hypothesis and that
would correspond to making a
quote-unquote discovery where we've
discovered something new and interesting
about the world hopefully
but how small is small enough so like
should we only reject the null
hypothesis of the p-values below
0.0001 or is it enough to reject the
null hypothesis provided that the
p-value is below 0.01
so oftentimes 5 or 0.05 is used as a cut
off for rejecting a null hypothesis but
that's kind of just an arbitrary number
that people use
and i always tell my students that the
reality is that how small that cutoff
should be depends on how bad it is to
make a mistake here and in particular a
what's called a type 1 error which i
think danielle is going to introduce
soon and we'll talk about this more in a
minute but that cutoff of 0.05 is very
field specific um and it's like by no
means a gold standard in any way
so okay the the thing we need to be
thinking about when we're doing
hypothesis testing is this table so this
is like the table of truth so we have
rows and we have columns and this two by
two table
and the columns tell us what reality is
so
the leftmost column
corresponds to the truth being h naught
so the null hypothesis really holds and
then the rightmost column is under the
alternative h a which is the alternative
holds so the null does not hold
and then there's two possible decisions
we can make those are shown in the rows
either we reject the null hypothesis or
we do not reject the null hypothesis
and of course in reality we never know
which column we're in we know which row
we're in but not which column we're in
exactly because the rows correspond to a
decision that we're making it's my
choice whether or not i reject the null
hypothesis but i i have no insight into
or
i don't know
no certainty about which column i'm in
so there's sort of four scenarios that
we can be in here
so the first scenario here this
corresponds to the null hypothesis
holding
and i decide not to reject h naught
and this is great this is a good place
to be because it means that there was
nothing interesting going on and i
didn't reject the null hypothesis
nothing to see here let's move right
along this is good
yeah in my courtroom example this sort
of corresponds to the defendant being
innocent and they they're not convicted
that would be good
okay so this is another thing we can be
happy about um here the null hypothesis
does not hold
and we rejected the null hypothesis
so here gareth how's your defendant
doing well guilty and convicted so we're
happy about that as well well
probably maybe some people might not be
i guess it depends on like what whether
what the crime was and that type of
thing but
we don't need to get into that probably
okay so now here this is what's called a
type two error and here the alternative
hypothesis holds
and we decided not to reject the null
hypothesis
so this is known as a type two error
and in this situation the
well actually here you tell us what
happened to your defendant well guilty
but uh he got off for it so that this is
a situation
they okay
uh it could be for example that uh the
defendant
uh was guilty there was evidence of
guilt but not overwhelming evidence and
of course on a jury where we're
instructed that we should not uh convict
someone unless we're sort of have
evidence beyond reasonable doubt and a
hypothesis test set up is similar to
that we may have suggestive evidence we
may have a test statistic that's
relatively large or a p-value that's
relatively small but not small enough to
actually be sure enough to reject the
null hypothesis exactly
all right and then finally the fourth
scenario
here the null hypothesis holds
but we rejected the null hypothesis
and this is known as a type one error
and type one errors are what we try to
avoid when we're doing hypothesis
testing
we or to put it a better way it's not
that we try to avoid them we try to
control them and saying that we try to
control them that's a statistical way of
saying we want to make sure we're not
making too many type one errors so
what's the type one error in your
courtroom example gareth well this is
the worst one right this is the innocent
person
she's innocent but convicted of the
crime so in this example
finally
we have someone who's innocent and
convicted of the crime and that's the
woman in this example
all right let's move on
so
so the the type 1 errors and type 2
errors are both mistakes we want to
ideally avoid both of them why why is it
the type 1 error that you chose to say
this is what we really want to avoid
this really has to do with the asymmetry
between the null hypothesis and the
alternative like the null hypothesis is
codifying like our default state of
belief about the world and there's got
to be like a lot of evidence for us to
change that default state of belief so
if we rejected the null hypothesis we're
saying like wow there was just like a
ton of evidence that's causing us to
change our minds about how the world
works change our entire understanding of
the world there must have been a lot of
evidence and we don't want to draw
conclusions like that willy-nilly and
that's why type 1 errors we really need
to be careful about it's sort of like if
um
the
the rejecting h naught
is like the headline in the newspaper
that's like vitamin c cures cancer
that's like you've rejected h naught h
naught is that vitamin c does not cure
cancer
if the headline is a vitamin c cures
cancer somebody rejected h naught and we
really really really want to make sure
that they are right we do not want that
to be a type one error right so in
medical studies we are most worried
about a type 1 euro because it suggests
that some treatment or drug or whatever
it is we're looking at is somehow has a
beneficial effect that in reality it
doesn't and obviously that can have a
large impact but then a type 2 error
is is also an issue here in practice we
would like to have both small type 1 and
type 2 errors but the reality is that to
minimize one error you actually tend to
make the other one larger so there's
always always some sort of trade-off
between the type 1 and type 2 errors and
the
sort of the standard setup is that we
believe the type 1 error is worse than a
type 2 error so it's not that we ignore
the type 2 error we still want it to be
relatively small but we concentrate more
on the type 1 error yeah and just to
wrap that thought up if if you're
familiar with the idea of power which
we're not going to get into today the
power of a hypothesis testing procedure
um the power is 1 minus the type two
error so that's how how well the
probability of a type is sorry yeah one
minus the probability of a type two
error thanks
great okay so the type one error rate is
the probability of making a type one
error and what we're gonna wanna do is
we're gonna want the type one error rate
to be small
and it turns out that there's a really
easy way to do this if we only ever
reject h naught when the p value is less
than alpha then the type 1 error rate
will be at most alpha so if you feel in
your heart that you want your type 1
error rate to be
no more than .05 then you should just
reject the null hypothesis whenever the
p-value is less than 0.05 and so on
or if you want your type 1 error rate to
be 0.01 or 0.001 then you should reduce
the null hypothesis whenever the p-value
is below 0.01 or 0.001
or
physicists will sometimes choose much
much smaller p-values here
because they'd like to be very very
certain about what they're doing well
the way that i would think about that as
well is like think about like what your
sample size is if you're like running
some kind of a study and your sample
size is like 20 or 30 or 40 it'll kind
of be hard to accrue enough evidence
against h naught to get a fantastically
small p-value but by contrast if you are
like
google and your sample size is like
every
click on like the google.com homepage in
like the last four days you have a
fantastically large sample size or
similarly if you're a physicist and
you're studying like subatomic particles
or whatever you might have a really
really big sample size and then you can
afford to use an alpha that's like 10 to
the negative six or something well that
raises a another issue here that if your
sample size is large enough
it is actually relatively easy to end up
with a very small p-value but only a
very small difference say in the means
between the control and treatment mice
let's say we found a million mice lying
around somewhere we perform these
hypothesis hypothesis tests we're very
likely to get a very small p-value but
that doesn't bias assuming that the
alternative holds assuming that the null
hypothesis doesn't hold but but the
reality is that the null hypothesis
almost never exactly holds so
if there's a very very small difference
between the control and treatment mice
if i have a large enough sample size i'm
almost certain to get a small p-value
even if there's a very very small
difference so sometimes people equate a
small p-value with telling us that
there's a large effect going on and the
reality is that if you have a large
sample size it might only be a very
small difference uh you're just sure
there is a difference but we don't
actually know how big that is that's
absolutely true and this is sort of the
difference between statistical
significance and practical significance
so often if the p-value is below let's
say .05 or 0.01 or 0.001 or whatever
threshold someone's using they'll say
that it's statistically significant well
that doesn't mean that it's practically
significant or scientifically important
gareth just before we leave the slide i
want to hear more about this scenario
where you found a million mice lying
around
we we just started remodeling our guest
house so
all right los angeles i guess must be a
thing